becoming a member of Congress has made
my life miserable
my life is also miserable because she's
in Congress so it's not it's not that
she didn't only do this to herself she
did it to many of us I mean before I got
here I've lost money since I've gotten
here I have people come up to me and say
crazy things to me
um out of the blue in public places yeah
um that they believe because they read
it on the Internet or saw it on some
some new show right that's never
happened to her about me uh so it's not
it's not a life that I think is is like
um something that I enjoy uh because you
can resign Marjorie you didn't have to
run for reelection by the way I don't
enjoy it but I'm committed to this job
because I believe in it I don't
understand
how poor white people in Georgia
love a woman who bemoans that she has to
work almost the entire year for only a
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars a year